welcome back to my series of Harry
Potter reviews I have had a great time
talking about The Sorcerer's Stone and
Chamber of Secrets and now we're moving
into the film that proved that the third
movies and franchises aren't always the
worst Harry Potter and the Prisoner of
Azkaban Chris Columbus decided not to
direct this movie and was replaced with
Alfonso Curran who made a beautiful
gorgeous film almost every shot in this
movie is dripping with gorgeous scenery
and fantastic lighting so in Harry
Potter's third year he's getting to that
point where he's no longer taking crap
from people his horrible guardians are
used to smacking him if he so much as
even talks a little bit and in this film
he decides nah no more of that in a
very entertaining sequence he turns an
incredibly annoying woman visiting his
house into a giant fat balloon and he
leaves and when Harry is walking through
this very deserted area in the middle of
the night I instantly realized this film
is going to be better than the last two
just on the merits of the editing alone
this is a very suspenseful II edited
film which leads us to an absurdly fun
sequence on the night bus
so this movie story surrounds the
character of Sirius Black played by Gary
Oldman he is a prisoner in Azkaban
prison and Harry learns that Sirius
Black just might be the person that
betrayed his parents getting them
murdered by Voldemort all the while
these cloaked beings called Dementors
are invading the world of Hogwarts
looking for Sirius Black causing a
serious stir amongst all of the students
and faculty something Alfonso Kuran
brought to this movie was a layer of
richness that the previous two films
didn't have there are so many small
moments in this film that build this
world that add a level of magic and
fantasy to it like this woman opening a
door and whatever is inside of it just
screaming and she's like nope not today
or Harry and his buddies eat beans that
allow them to make noises like various
animals or the Fantastic Hippogriff
sequence where Harry is riding it along
the water and it just sticks its claws
into the water for a moment these small
moments are what make this movie really
special there's also a scene early on in
this movie involving a hunchback that
caused me to laugh so hard I was
actually ashamed mmm so Harry gets on
this train harmony is there Ron is there
it's cool to see these characters back
together again which something I love in
every single one of these movies and
that's one of the reasons these movies
work so well these characters you feel
for them you love them you enjoy seeing
them together that casting is just so on
point but this one instantly lets us
know is going to be slightly darker than
the other two when those Dementors walk
into this train and this imagery is so
gorgeous this is such a beautifully
directed movie I can't talk enough about
it in this movie we have Professor Lupin
who as you know if you've read the book
or seen this movie which you probably
have is actually a werewolf and this is
something that JK Rowling does a lot
with her characters she has a sort of
hint in their name Lupin lupus wolf
werewolf canine you get it also
something I loved in this movie was
seeing Hagrid actually get to teach
which is when we meet that awesome
Hippogriff creature and oh my gosh this
thing is so cool I wish this thing was
real this is one of my favorite things
about the Harry Potter universe and also
one of my least favorite things about it
because there's so many great
in this world that you just love seeing
and love reading in the books and you
just want it to be real but it's not
real this thing is so cool I want that
thing as my pet and again like I
mentioned earlier Harry has stopped
taking from people in this movie he
directly opposes Draco in this film and
that was a lovely to see that little
snot-nosed brat getting slapped around
once again fantastic stuff and even
better later is when Hermione stops
taking from Draco - that felt good
and again the magic of this world is
expanded with this awesome scene where
Professor Lupin teaches the kids to turn
things they're afraid of into something
funny not only is that a good message
for kids but it was an extremely
entertaining scene there's also this
really cool thing called the marauders
map in this movie that Harry comes
across that allows him to see where
anyone is walking or moving about in
Hogwarts all day or night and there's a
very suspenseful scene in the hallway at
night where he's positive he is about to
face off with this person he's looking
for that supposedly dead now if you've
seen the movie you know this guy ends up
being a rat at the end and if you listen
very carefully in the hallway scene you
can actually hear a rat scurrying along
in the background it's so clever it
doesn't cheat at all also the special
effects in this movie have been highly
improved or the first two and it only
came out two years after Chamber of
Secrets did the Quidditch scene has more
depth in the rain it looks very very
cool and all of the creatures actually
still hold up very well 12 years later
today when I rewatched this movie
something else I loved in this movie is
that Ron and Hermione they're arguing a
lot they're arguing slightly different
than friends argue it is definitely a
couples argument they just don't realize
it yet this movie is also considerably
more funny than the last two like this
fantastic scene that has no impact on
the story but is just meant to make our
characters more rich what what is want
me did that bounce I don't want to tap
down they tell the spiders wrong
and we finally get to meet Gary Oldman
as Sirius Black and we learned some
things about his past that are extremely
important to Harry's growth this is
actually someone who wants to help Harry
he's not evil villain this guy is
wronged he's innocent even offers to let
Harry live with him which if you've ever
looked at Harry's Guardians you know is
a pretty damn good deal Lupin is
revealed to be a werewolf Sirius Black
wasn't hiding as a dog throughout the
entire film these two have a battle and
this is where the film gets amazing I
absolutely love the back and time
sequence it feels so in the moment
there's something incredibly visceral
about this so important so drastically
imperative about this sequence there's
just something about the way it's edited
together acted directed the music from
John Williams master that just makes it
so exciting this entire finale is so
well done Harry Potter and the Prisoner
of Azkaban is one of the best Harry
Potter movies and I'm going to give it
an A it is definitely one of my
favorites of the franchise and it marked
a great change of pace for the series of
Harry Potter I love it what do you guys
think of the Prisoner of Azkaban look
forward to my upcoming review of Harry
Potter and the Goblet of Fire you guys
are the best thank you so much as always
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
you